El litio se está convirtiendo en uno de los
minerales más cotizados de todo el planeta.
Hablamos de una materia prima absolutamente
indispensable para llevar a cabo los ambiciosos
planes de transición energética.
Y, precisamente por eso, ya está moviendo
inversiones multimillonarias.
N1 (Ya se está construyendo la primera gran
refinería de litio de Europa, ¿es suficiente?
Reino Unido acogerá la primera gran refinería
de litio de Europa por parte de Green Lithium.
Su capacidad productiva anual será de 50.000
toneladas de este material, lo que servirá
para cubrir el 6% la demanda de coches eléctricos
en Europa para 2030. HibridosYElectricos)
C1 (Lithium Batteries Are the New Oil. Elon
Musk)
(“Las baterías de litio son el nuevo petróleo”.
Elon Musk)
Ahora bien, ¿dónde se encuentran exactamente
las grandes fuentes de litio para abastecer
la enorme demanda que está surgiendo? ¿Qué
implicaciones puede tener esta especie de
nuevo “oro blanco” para los países productores?
¿Puede ser el conocido como triángulo del
litio una gran oportunidad para que se produzca
un nuevo renacer económico en América del
Sur.
Queridos amigos, amigas, en este vídeo vamos
a responder a todas estas preguntas.
Arranquemos.
[Pero antes solo un segundo. La demanda del
litio se está disparando, sí, pero también
lo está haciendo la demanda de cobre, el
tercer metal más extraído de todo el planeta.
De hecho se espera que la demanda de este
mineral se doble en poco más de 10 años.
Solo hay un problema: hoy por hoy no se está
invirtiendo ni de lejos lo necesario para
poder abastecer toda esta inmensa demanda.
Y, claro, como os podéis imaginar, poner
en marcha una gran explotación minera de
cobre lleva mucho tiempo.
La situación es tal que muchos expertos están
alertando de que la crisis del cobre es inminente.
Pero ¿Queréis saber más sobre esta crisis
que parece inminente? ¿Qué puede suponer
la escasez de cobre? ¿Cómo se puede evitar?
¿Puede ser una buena invertir en este mineral?
Pues bien, os tenéis todos los detalles en
uno de los últimos vídeos de Si lo Hubiera
Sabido, el canal de información financiera
de mutuactivos con el que participamos. Os
dejamos el enlace en la descripción.
Dicho esto, arranquemos.]
Aunque escuchemos hablar de él por todas
partes, hace poco más de una década no era
ni de lejos tan importante. Por supuesto,
eso, cambió cuando comenzaron a popularizarse
los coches eléctricos e híbridos.
Esta era la previsión en 2008…
C2 (El Consejo Nacional de Investigación
concluyó que el litio, aunque no era crítico
en el momento de la evaluación de 2008, podría
llegar a serlo en función del nivel de crecimiento
de nuevos usos, como las baterías de vehículos
híbridos.
Critical Mineral Resources of the United States—Economic
and Environmental Geology and Prospects for
Future Supply)
Y hoy ya es una realidad. El uso del litio
para fabricar baterías se ha multiplicado
por 15 durante la última la década. Una
creciente demanda que por supuesto también
ha hecho explotar la producción. Fijaos.
De las 130 mil toneladas aproximadas que se
producen de litio cada año, cerca de las
tres cuartas partes, más de 96 mil toneladas
se destinan a la fabricación de baterías.
Evidentemente, con semejante demanda, como
os podéis imaginar, se ha disparado la inversión
para encontrar nuevos yacimientos y poner
en marcha nuevas explotaciones.
Ahora bien, ¿sabéis a qué países les está
tocando la lotería del oro blanco?
Pues… Estos que veis en pantalla son los
10 países con los mayores recursos de litio
identificados hasta ahora. ¿Os llama algo
la atención?
Exacto, hoy por hoy, el cono sur de América
concentra más del 50% de todos los recursos
identificados en el mundo. Prácticamente,
podríamos decir que el Cono Sur es para el
Litio, lo que Oriente Medio es para el petróleo.
Es lo que se conoce como el Triangulo del
Litio.
Y, además, si a eso le sumamos que esta región,
particularmente Chile, también es uno de
los mayores productores de cobre, que como
comentábamos antes es el otro mineral clave
en el proceso de transición energético,
ya os podéis hacer una idea del enorme peso
que de repente está cobrando esta región.
De una forma u otra, cada vez que veis las
siglas ESG o escucháis hablar de combatir
el cambio climático, estáis hablando de
un gran negocio potencial para estos tres
países.
El cono sur, Argentina, Chile y Bolivia son
actores clave para que los gobiernos y las
empresas de todo el mundo puedan cumplir sus
planes.
La pregunta lógicamente es: ¿qué están
haciendo estos países para aprovechar la
carrera del litio? ¿Qué puede suponer tener
unos recursos tan grandes de lo que Elon Musk
ha calificado como el nuevo petróleo? ¿Hasta
qué punto el oro blanco puede ayudar a estos
países?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T1 (¿UN NUEVO DESPERTAR?)
Lo primero que tenemos que tener claro es
que aunque los mayores recursos identificados
de litio estén en el cono sur, solo Chile
se sitúa hoy por hoy entre los mayores productores
del mundo. Australia es el número 1. En este
país se produce cerca de la mitad de todo
el litio mundial.
Pero insisto, en América del Sur, que casi,
casi podríamos considerar como el corazón
mundial de este mineral, Chile es quien ha
tomado la delantera, produce ya casi el 30%
de todo el litio que se extrae a nivel mundial.
Bolivia y Argentina tienen grandes planes,
pero estos están avanzo más lentamente que
en Chile. Un país donde se están tomando
esta cuestión con una gran prioridad nacional.
Sin ir más lejos, en abril 2023, el presidente
Boric anunció su “Estrategia Nacional del
Litio”. Uno de sus puntos más importantes
es la nacionalización de este recurso. De
hecho, el presidente chileno anunció la creación
de la Empresa Nacional del Litio y la otorgación
de contratos de exploración y explotación
tanto a Enami, la Empresa Nacional de Minería,
como a Codelco, la empresa estatal del cobre.
Además, según sus planes, el Estado promoverá
la generación de productos de litio de mayor
valor añadido, como baterías. También anunció
la creación de un Instituto Chileno del Litio
para llevar a cabo tareas de investigación
y desarrollo sobre esta industria.
Es decir, en Chile, el mayor productor de
América del Sur, el litio será una actividad
básicamente pública.
El anuncio despertó la oposición de muchos
actores privados chilenos, pero lo cierto
es que no es una sorpresa. Si algo caracteriza
a Chile es la producción de cobre… Y, ¿sabéis
qué? Lleva casi un siglo nacionalizado. De
hecho, esto es algo presente incluso en la
constitución.
C3 (“La gran minería del cobre y las empresas
consideradas como tal, nacionalizadas en virtud
de lo prescrito en la disposición 17º transitoria
de la Constitución Política de 1925, continuará
rigiéndose por las normas constitucionales
vigentes a la fecha de promulgación de esta
Constitución.” Tercera disposición transitoria
de la Constitución de Chile (vigente a mayo
de 2023)
El Estado chileno mantiene vínculos y programas
de cooperación con el sector privado, pero
en última instancia la actividad de exploración
y explotación del cobre depende de las empresas
públicas. Y, ahora, eso es exactamente lo
que Boric quiere hacer con el Litio.
(“El estado participará en todo el ciclo
productivo de este mineral, creando para ello
una empresa Nacional del litio [...] Este
proceso compatriotas permitirá acelerar la
exploración de los salares.)
De esta forma, la participación de empresas
privadas en esta industria se hará siempre
acompañando a las empresas públicas. Es
un modelo que con el cobre les ha funcionado
y ahora con el litio quieren repetir.
Sea como sea, Chile tiene un plan de acción
bastante más claro que el de sus vecinos.
Y eso que si hablamos de precursores y visionarios,
tenemos que mencionar sí o sí a Evo Morales,
que ya en abril del año 2008 promulgó un
Decreto que declaraba “de prioridad nacional
la industrialización del Salar de Uyuni para
el desarrollo productivo, económico y social
del Departamento de Potosí”.
En el caso de Bolivia, el gobierno, no optó
por llevar a cabo una nacionalización completa,
sino a trozos. Es decir, el proceso se hace
por yacimientos. El problema es que eso no
genera mucha seguridad jurídica porque no
sabes cuándo van a cambiar las tornas, así
que la inversión privada no despegó.
Para arreglar esta situación, en 2017 se
creó la empresa Yacimientos de Litio Bolivianos,
pero, aun así, la producción de litio continúa
sin despegar en el país. Por supuesto, las
fuertes tensiones políticas que existen en
el país tampoco están ayudando.
Y como la cosa no va nada bien pese a todas
las expectativas creadas pues… Fijaos.
N2 (11 de julio de 2022: Evo Morales pide
nacionalizar el litio para que América Latina
sea ‘potencia’. Forbes)
N3 (21 de marzo del 2023: Luis Arce denuncia
que el litio de Bolivia está “amenazado
por la derecha internacional” Con la tecnología
convencional, mediante piscinas de evaporación,
Bolivia solo ha logrado producir 600 toneladas
al año de carbonato de litio, por lo que
todavía no ha entrado en el club de los grandes
jugadores en el mercado de esta materia prima.
El País)
Para intentar salir de esta especie de hoyo
y conseguir que la producción repunte, ahora
los líderes bolivianos se están echando
en manos de socios rusos y chinos.
N4 (Bolivia recibirá 1.290 millones en inversiones
de dos empresas de Rusia y China para su industria
del litio. EuropaPress)
Veremos qué ocurre.
Mientras tanto, en la Argentina, ¿qué os
voy a contar? Todo dependerá del resultado
de las elecciones. El litio en el país gaucho
no está nacionalizado. De hecho, en buena
medida ha quedado sujeto a las regulaciones
provinciales. Provincias que en líneas generales
buscan atraer la inversión privada. Quizás
porque ven que puede ser la fórmula más
rápida para poner en marcha las explotaciones.
Sin embargo, a medida que se han ido acercando
las elecciones… La idea de la nacionalización
ha vuelto a ponerse sobre la mesa.
N5 (3 de mayo de 2023: Diputados impulsan
proyecto para nacionalizar el litio: la línea
de Cristina Kirchner y la idea de una "nueva
YPF". La iniciativa declara "de interés público
la exploración, explotación, concesión
de explotación, industrialización y todos
los actos relativos al litio y sus derivados".
Se trata del artículo clave del proyecto
al plantear la nacionalización de toda la
cadena de producción de este recurso. Iprofesional)
Claro que nacionalizado o no, el mayor beneficiario
de la explotación sería por supuesto el
gobierno. Eso está atado y bien atado.
C4 (“Si sumamos toda la carga fiscal, independientemente
de si es nacional o provincial, Argentina
es uno de los países más caros de la región,
en comparación con Chile o Perú. Somos poco
competitivos a nivel de costo fiscal”, Cámara
Argentina de Empresarios Mineros (CAEM).
En cualquier caso, los proyectos avanzan.
C5 (“Con el funcionamiento de los proyectos
en construcción sumado a las ampliaciones
previstas de los proyectos activos, Argentina
podrá sextuplicar su producción (hasta más
de 200.000 tn ) en esta década”. Litio
y su potencial para el desarrollo minero argentino–
Ministerio de Economía de Argentina (Diciembre
2022)
A los precios actuales, eso podría suponer
unos ingresos de unos 6.000 millones de dólares
anuales. No es una cantidad equiparable a
los ingresos que generan las petromonarquías,
pero a largo plazo el litio puede jugar un
papel clave a la hora de impulsar la economía
de estos países.
Pero… Sigamos.
Luego, aunque lógicamente no forma parte
del triángulo del litio y sus recursos identificados
son mucho más reducidos, tenemos el caso
de México, cuyas reservas identificadas,
no obstante, se sitúan entre las 10 más
grandes del mundo.
Pues bien, en el caso del país azteca, en
abril del 2022 el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador dictó la reforma de la ley
de minería de México. Entre sus puntos principales
encontramos… La nacionalización de toda
la cadena de producción de esta materia prima.
De esta forma, la exploración, la explotación,
el beneficio y aprovechamiento del litio quedan
exclusivamente a cargo del Estado
Y así es como surgió “Litio para México”,
LitioMx.
A partir de ahora, excepto para aquellas concesiones
ya otorgadas, el estado mexicano asumirá
en exclusiva todas las operaciones relacionadas
con este mineral.
Ahora bien, ¿realmente podemos hablar de
un nuevo despertar?
Pues mucho ojo porque en el pasado estos países
ya han perdido muchas oportunidades. Sus reservas
de litio son inmensas, pero las reservas conocidas
a nivel mundial están creciendo con fuerza.
Y tanto Chile como, sobre todo, Bolivia, Argentina
y México se enfrentan a un importante problema:
en el caso de la minería no son países particularmente
atractivos. Eso es algo que en el caso de
Chile puede no ser un gran problema: el país
tiene recursos, experiencia y sus empresas
públicas funcionan razonablemente bien.
Sin embargo, los casos de Argentina, Bolivia
y México son completamente diferentes. En
cierto modo, un desastre… Y eso podría
hacerles perder esta oportunidad. ¿Por qué?
Pues porque ser los primeros podría animar
la llegada de muchas inversiones vinculadas
para producir productos de mayor valor añadido
con el litio. Sin embargo, en lugar de intentar
aprovechar esa circunstancia, Bolivia, México
y Argentina siguen atascados.
Eso sí, México sí que tiene una importante
ventaja: su enorme industria automotriz. De
hecho, es uno de los 10 mayores fabricantes
de automóviles de todo el mundo. ¿Y qué
quiere decir eso? Qué podría tener mucha
facilidad para desarrollar una cadena de producción
completa vinculada al litio. La oportunidad
es muy clara. Pero para lograrlo, el gobierno
mexicano debería hacer las cosas de una forma
muy diferente a como las hace con PEMEX. Y
eso no parece nada fácil.
En cualquier caso, que los países latinoamericanos
se pongan las pilas -nunca mejor dicho- es
algo que no solo les importa a ellos. Atentos.
T2 (SEGURIDAD ANTE TODO)
Desde el punto de vista geopolítico, el litio
tiene una importante ventaja: la inmensa mayor
parte de la producción y también de las
reservas se encuentran en países razonablemente
tranquilos con altos niveles de libertad,
al menos si los comparamos con muchos de los
productores de otras materias primas como
el petróleo.
Y, ojo, porque es algo que puede garantizar
la seguridad del suministro… Y podéis creerme
si os digo que tras la invasión rusa de Ucrania,
ahora esto es algo que en Occidente se empieza
a tomar más en serio, especialmente en el
viejo continente.
De hecho, la Comisión Europea ya ha puesto
su ojo en el conocido como el triángulo del
litio. Y de hecho eso es lo que explica noticias
como estas:
N6 (17 de julio de 2023: La UE firma un acuerdo
con Argentina para obtener litio y cobre a
cambio de promover las renovables. EuropaPress)
N7 (18 de julio de 2023: La UE firma un acuerdo
con Chile para obtener litio y cobre a cambio
de impulsar su industria. La alianza contempla
también promover la industria y las cadenas
de valor de este sector. El Periódico de
la Energía)
La Unión Europea está dispuesta a invertir
45.000 millones de euros en América Latina
para asegurarse un acceso fiable a recursos
tan importantes como el litio y el cobre.
Es decir, que el dinero y el negocio están
sobre la mesa. Bolivia, Argentina y México
tienen que ponerse las pilas para explotar
cuanto antes esta oportunidad. Chile al menos
ya lo está haciendo.
Sea como sea, llegados hasta aquí, la pregunta
es para ti:
¿Crees que Argentina, Bolivia y México lograrán
aprovechar la oportunidad del litio?
¿Pueden llegar los países latinoamericanos
a desarrollar actividades de mayor valor añadido
que la simple minería? ¿Cuál crees que
sería la mejor solución para impulsar la
producción del litio?
Déjanos tus impresiones en los comentarios
y abramos debate.
Y ahora, si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante,
no olvides darle a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik
si es que aún no lo has hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.